there
[Music]
where are you taking me
[Music]
i asked you a question
everyone says reyes is a good shot yeah
and i'll put arrows through both of us
you're switching with me
it's a snap
we're not gonna make it
[Music]
blameless maraud had me released from
prison
but why
redemption is still possible
climb the mountain
find out why the machines are attacking
[Applause]
do that
and you shall be a free man
it will take all your wits
your skills
and courage
you have walked in the shadows reyes
[Music]
now it is time to climb
into the light
hi i'm ben mccaw narrative director at
gorilla
i hope you enjoyed your first look at
horizon call of the mountain coming
exclusively to playstation vr2 we're
also happy to announce that a big update
to horizon forbidden west including new
game plus will be available to download
on playstation 4 and playstation 5 today
so
for details on this free update please
check out playstation blog from all of
us at gorilla thank you for your
continued support and please stay tuned
for more updates to come